hyderabad is drowning
the rain has been relentless in the
south indian city
and it's now claimed lives in one deadly
incident
floodwaters pushed a wall onto a house
which collapsed on
impact other victims were swept away
in raging currents
rescue teams have been working day and
night but
they can't get to everyone residents in
some areas say they've had no help
at all around 500
to 2000 houses were submerged in water
since yesterday night and nobody visited
this place so far
people are suffering kids are suffering
there is no food no water
no milk no facilities to go out
catastrophic scenes also in cambodia
deadly flash floods have hit the west of
the country prompting the evacuation of
some two and a half thousand people
the military and police have been
deployed to assist with the massive
operation
and hand out much needed food to
isolated communities
and this is the scene in neighboring
vietnam where flooding has claimed the
most casualties in the last week
up to a million people have been
impacted by the floods
some 200 000 homes are underwater and
there are fears the death toll could
rise after catastrophic landslides hit a
mountainous area
in central vietnam and
there's no relief in sight more bad
weather is expected as tropical storm
nanka pummels the country
and eight groups say it could overwhelm
even the most resilient communities
and joining me for more is hong known a
program coordinator for the
international federation of the red
cross and red crescent societies in
bangkok in thailand
mr gnuan welcome what is the scale of
the
damage that we are seeing in vietnam and
cambodia
yes the the tropical depressions
have induced a significant and heavy
rain
in the past many days in
vietnam and cambodia and lao as well
so the the floods has caused
significant and serious damages
to almost 100
000 households in
several provinces of the central vietnam
and it is also clear that close to a
million
people will be affected by these
floods because of their homes are
inundated
in the water and their belongings are
destroyed
and including their livelihoods
in cambodia according to the national
disaster
management committee that it is also
having a serious issues and flooding
which is forced
around 100 000 people has been
also affected right now this flooding uh
comes
amid the ongoing coronavirus pandemic
is that having a double impact on people
absolutely i mean these floods are a
double
whammy making it even tougher for
millions of people already struggling
with the economic fail-out
of the coveted 19 pandemic that has
destroyed their incomes and livelihoods
what is the government doing about these
double whammies as you call them is the
government being able to cope
at the moment the government is
giving up their priorities into
search and rescue and
saving live efforts together with
the local authorities and
red cross as well so
of course i mean the with like what i
just mentioned
the uh the covet 19 pandemic
has already overwhelmed the capacity
of the communities so i think there is
something that
internationals community also have to
look into this and try our best to live
up and to work together so that
affected people will be able to access
to relief
and recovery
a spirit of cooperation is what has been
the theme generally through this
coronavirus pandemic but are you really
seeing
that international help in trying to
help these affected communities
sorry can you repeat the question are
you really seeing
help coming from the international
community to aid the work that you are
doing
or that the governments are doing to try
and help these affected communities
well i think is with this kind of
situation storm after storm
floods after floods and blasts with the
call midnight in panama and i think it
is
also even for a very well preparedness
and
resilient communities it is also
something
already you know uh too much
so i think that it is not the
business of every individual
government or any organization but i
think we need to
to come together and
and sort it out hong kong from the
international federation of the red
cross and red crescent societies
thank you so much for speaking with us
thank you
you